hey I'm Kane a couple months ago I
helped Kristen from ladylike redecorate
her desk you all seemed really into it
after that I helped Freddie redecorate
her bedroom space so she could spend
more stress-free time in there I really
do believe that we'd all be a little
happier if we had our own versions of an
oasis that we could go home to today I'm
meeting up with Melina who wanted help
redesigning her living space for her
adult son who happens to have autism
come on check it out this is your new
living true home oh she wanted help
figuring out how to make their space
uniquely adult and hopefully help them
transition into the new phases of their
lives
my name is Melina Fernandez burn and I'm
a mom and I have two boys 18 and 21 as a
mom you think they're gonna be children
forever now that they really are adults
it would be a great way to bring in the
new phases of adult life it is just a
special time of coming into your own
what is autism autism is a neurological
developmental disorder it doesn't mean
they have low cognition it just means if
they're on the spectrum they're going to
be impacted on a social communication
level on an executive functioning level
what is the spectrum you the spectrum
means somebody can be impacted minimally
somebody can be impacted extensively
where it is Colin clinical he's
considered high-functioning but it's
kind of a misnomer even though they're
high-functioning and very able in
certain areas they still may be
challenged maybe in an emergency or to
defend themselves or to express how is
Colin diagnosed without Selenia when he
was about two and a half I took him to a
state agency the only assess him for
delayed speech and as a new parent
that's the hardest most difficult path
to be denied he even has a diagnosis and
then the school district declined all
services because he did not have autism
that was really a difficult time after a
year researched a lot and I'd noticed
other behaviors finally took him to a
psychologist who did diagnose him at the
age of four why is it important to
diagnose it earlier when caught young
their brain is truly rewiring on a
minute-by-minute basis if you can use
that momentum of growth to remediate
sensory processing issues eating issues
balance issues motor skills those are
things that are just a big challenge
for the autism community that Molina
gave me a tour of her space and I got to
hang out with Cullen a bit this is where
Colin really enjoys watching the Lakers
and the Dodger games what kinds of
things do you do in this area I go on
the iPad and watch TV I watch YouTube
what percentage of time do you think
Colin's been in this area I would say
this is 85% of his day where's your
favorite spot in this living room that
was so fun right there I got comfy yeah
the minute he gets home from school is
to take off the shoes and lay down what
made you decide to have such a big
sectional colin is almost six feet he
needs space that's good to know
no well this table is interesting whoa
it raises nicely and it also stores we
don't quite need this table as much as
we did when they were younger the wall
unit is your traditional piece we're all
through CDs and DVDs and books go in
this nook used to be where we would
store our bicycles you see it kind of
the bike tires and the space isn't that
large either it would be great if it was
used for something in particular it's
not been the easiest to figure it out
you said that you were into meditation
and things like that I'm teaching him a
little bit of the stillness of the mind
using essential oils native scene really
nice impact on Colin I constantly have
new age and soothing music on this
particular area is very challenging it's
in between two doors so you have a very
small corner are there any particular
things in here that you first fear
wanting no okay really enjoy call it an
eye plane in this room is Smash Ball and
we've gotten really good at it good job
one more time okay okay he's nice
amazing good like ping-pong kind of
after getting a tour of the living room
I wanted to see if I might be able to
help with Colin's bedroom the space
isn't too big I don't know quite where
to put this bed in terms of direction
the blinds were here fairly old they've
been with us since we moved here now
that he's 21 trying to figure out for an
adult what's the best for him I like the
color a lot okay what's your favorite
color blue he's great with blue yeah he
chose it it's very calming I'm seeing
some white photos so I can draw on it
when's the last time you redid the space
I would say about 810 years ago the boys
taste there
older now I would like to sort of inject
their adult myths into this space are
there things you're afraid of protecting
themselves it has to be one of my
biggest fears is him being taken
advantage you can teach them but you
can't be insured even though he has the
most traditional forms of autism he's
still so thoughtful what are some of the
best things that you've learned from him
the most important thing you taught me
was what's important sincerely which is
it's all in the heart it's just so easy
to get bummed out I mean it's a
devastating diagnosis for any parent you
doesn't think so much about tomorrow he
thinks a lot about now in the times in
the years I forgot he taught me how to
bring it back to the heart if you didn't
decide instead of being devastated
you're gonna shift into being thankful
no matter what it really can be a
journey of your own growth what are some
cool things about your mom she is kind
and helpful now that he's older at a
vocational school
I'd like to transform this space more
matches where he's at in life after
getting a tour of Lena's home taking a
few photos and getting a feel for the
family's vibe and what they really
needed and I got to work I usually like
to draw out potential ideas to see what
I could do with the space the first
thing you see when entering the living
room is a giant TV wall unit it's big
it's heavy and very 90s my aunts and
uncles totally you had this in their
living room feels very heavy I wanted an
unassuming TV console just enough to
hold their electronics and found a great
one in a darker wood tone from home
goods it features a unique sliding barn
door that makes it stand out I wanted to
mount the TV the TV was actually really
light and weight and the pros from handy
comm hung it up securely on the wall
just like a piece of artwork since Colin
clearly loves love's love's his couch I
didn't want to swap it out in case he
didn't like how the new one felt but the
shade of brown really made the couch
feel way older than it was so I wanted
to change the color to gray with couch
covers I found really great ones from
Bed Bath & Beyond they worked really
well for two of the sectional pieces I
didn't realize how extra-long the third
sectional piece would be
what's going on kid this is too small
the coffee table they had felt really
heavy kind of like a giant brick I
wanted to swap it out for a sleeker one
in a darker tone with minimal
compartments I found the perfect one at
Z Gallerie
it looks so good and is functional with
drawers for board games art supplies and
remote controls only two pieces of
furniture in and I'm already super
excited the blinds also feel pretty
outdated here so I'm gonna swap these
out for a row of teal curtains over a
set of sheer white curtains I found
beautiful ones along with sturdy curtain
rods from TJ Maxx halfway through the
day it dawned on me that none of the
lamps I had ordered online were here we
can't find those fixed lamps they're
supposed to be delivered and they're all
perfectly chosen for this space
otherwise I have to run out and go pick
some lamps somehow I thought that they
still might arrive today so we just kept
moving hoping for the best for this
little nook area Molina had no idea what
she wanted to do with it after she
mentioned her interest in meditation I
knew right away I wanted to surprise her
with a little meditation area I wanted a
little accent wall here it's the same
wallpaper we used for Freddie's bedroom
from chasing paper I wanted to paint
over all the bike tire marks and
scratches on the wall so the room could
be reset and renewed at this point in
the day I realized that none of the
lamps would be coming I check the
tracking the lamps aren't coming till
tomorrow if you know me you know I love
lamps and there was no way I was gonna
reveal the living space to the family
without the proper lighting I decided to
find brand-new lamps from scratch so I
explained as quickly as I could what I
wanted so they could work on it while I
was gone
I don't usually panic I'm not a panic ER
isolate you've had it here right now
I just want it to be perfect for them
I'll be fine everything else looks great
what do you feel right now
somehow by a true miracle I found all
the lamps I wanted from t.j.maxx
I'm so happy I feel better I feel better
I got lamps I got names look at this
beauty I also asked the handycam pros to
help put wallpaper above the couch wall
I picked out a white wallpaper with a
soft leaf design from wayfair.com
I wanted to brighten up the space while
keeping a cute they helped me cut the
pieces to the right sizes to put up they
call me and said that the wallpaper
didn't have adhesive which is different
from the wallpaper that I used for
Freddy's bedroom and that was a lot
easier just to like peel off when I got
back we were down to the wire well I was
out getting lamps I picked up a spray on
adhesive for the living room wallpaper
while I was out I found a giant 9 by 14
feet gray fabric sheet for the long side
of the sectional sofa I want to do a
side table here to create a small gap
between the sectional pieces I found a
cute lightweight side table to break up
the giant sectional feel I want to put a
tall plant in the back corner one on the
side table and one in the coffee table I
found really awesome fake plants of all
kinds at Marshall's I had no idea they
even sold fake plants there you just
keep huffing of everything you can tell
how happy I was just a tree I'm so happy
I love big trees I want to put a giant
rug here to help break up all the tan
carpeting it was kind of hard to find
rugs at the size I wanted but eventually
I found the perfect light blue one I
want to put a tall lamp here and one on
the side table which will sit next to a
Google home which I got from Best Buy
for the couch pillows I went with shades
of blue I got the piece of artwork here
from TJ Maxx which again are different
shades of blue and green to emphasize
the theme and to tie it all back
together so for the rest of the
meditation area I want to put a big
piece of artwork here I found one from
TJ Maxx that reminded me so much of
Molina
I want the meditation area to have a bit
of privacy so I want a curtain here I
went with the white sheer ish curtain
with teal accents this way the color
would
match the living room and the slightly
more ornate design would match the vibe
of the meditation area for the rest of
the meditation area I wanted to serene
licking lamps here big plants on either
side and a very soft rug I went with a
few eclectic pillows in Burgundy gold
and magenta so for this corner of the
room Molina had no idea what she wanted
to do with it I noticed that it was kind
of the perfect place to put a desk I
found one that I really liked from the
Container Store it was a darker tone and
would match the coffee table and TV
console on it would be a lamp in the
plant another plant on the floor to help
fill up the space a piece of artwork
here one with the message that again
reminded me so much of Molina maybe a
mirror here this way it would reflect
the big sliding glass door across the
room to create an illusion that maybe it
could be an actual window call I just
came back to school and we are putting
in the lab but the rooms still a mess of
a shower tabs what are you looking
forward to the most we are looking
forward to the transformation for Justin
II about what what they might change it
to how's this excited yes so moving on
to Colin's bedroom Molina really wanted
to make it feel more adult since the
baby blue walls were so
attention-grabbing
I didn't want to add too many other
colors it would either clash or make it
feel more childlike so I got this soft
light gray duvet cover fluffy pillows
and matching grey pillow cases from Bed
Bath & Beyond I want to Center the bed
put two wooden nightstands on either
side lamps on top of the nightstands
plants on the other side also I want
maybe a headboard here I ended up
getting a big sticker with wood graphic
on it for an illusion headboard and it
ended up matching the nightstands really
well some kind of artwork here I've got
a thin white mirror because it just
looked really peaceful and it paired
well with some of the white pillows on
the bed of course I want to remove the
blinds here also swapping it out for
neutral gray curtains to match the gray
bedding I also layered the grey curtains
over the row of sheer white curtains and
a very soft grey rug here
this drawer I'm moving against the wall
with the window to open up the walkway a
bit I want to put a lamp here and a
plant leave up some of the trophies in
all the lamps I put in color-changing
philips hue light bulb this way they can
either control the lights on their phone
or they can control it through their
voice by the Google home I picked up
this mine is a little dark so I'm gonna
put Philips hue blue like a fancy
restaurant or something last-minute tree
and I've put everything together gonna
start filling in the place lastly before
the reveal to the family Colin has a few
piles of books and other knickknacks
throughout his room and I wanted a place
for him to put it so I picked up two
seafoam colored storage Ottomans for him
to put books in and this way it could
also double as seating for his room it's
coming together it's looking good
videos are from handy good job guys
it looks amazing so after running around
all day right now I'm about to reveal
the living space for the very first time
to Melina and her two sons Colin and
Brendon I really hope they like it
alright come down okay guys come on
check it out Wow oh my goodness this is
your new living shirt okay well how can
I'm really impressed
like it's des right here look at that
corner over there it makes it seem like
it's in another room entirely and even
though you can use them for different
things they belong in the same place
it's really nice the way the flow is
it's just really cool can't wait to use
the desk
yeah kinds of things this is a surprise
like a meditation area yeah this is
curtains this is a really cozy spot yeah
this is like a layers dead but he's
closed a crazy show right here a lot of
people want a space that is cozy and yet
not very stimulating I know that you
have tons of books in your rooms this
could be like a little reading corner or
meditation Brendon you can just lay down
and read it yeah oh dang think Colin
look at the pink lights behind you isn't
that neat yes the pattern right here on
the wall the leaves that's pretty cool
Kylie don't ya this is your new living
room this is great Kane what's your
favorite spot the sofa yeah yes that's
your favorite corner over there so I
wanted to make sure I kept it the same
the desk is level with the sofa like
that yeah a little more light with the
bottom clear you've got the dimensions
perfectly got the TV right here I like
the wall set up and that colors are
perfectly stimulating and they very very
soothing
you guys like blue a lot so I wanted to
go off that color tone and I love your
artwork you got it just right and then
some of these artworks to it reminded me
a lot of what you said during the
interview I wanted to create a
comfortable space for you to maybe play
board games again
your family time together play in the
yard and come in and just relax you
really used everything that was here and
you made it functional let's go check
out Colin's room yeah oh
[Music]
goodness oh I'm jealous this is another
transformation the blue now really
stands out because you have the perfect
colors of white and brown you like it
call it's good it's great huh yeah this
is a very small room and you made it
look like a master almost and I love the
way you can walk all around and there's
not that big dresser that was in the way
out there in the corner you know water
right here glad know how to put this
together mister yeah there's more
storage space in the Ottomans and the
nightstands two wonderful items here
plants too and the lighting it warms up
the spot and this one is also
controllable so you can change it to
different colors whatever you're feeling
the transparent curtains you could cover
it completely if you wanted to or just
like I have a little bit of light coming
through different vibe mm-hmm how do the
currents make you feel any good rug is
very soft - yeah Wow
it looks comfortable you feel these
pillows Cohen they're so soft that's
soft almost like cottage yeah and the
woods like a little bit more mature I
love this headboard cane and it's
sticker the mirror up there boy does it
perfectly complements the bed really
balances this is just right yeah if
you're gonna spend more time in here
yeah all right I'd like to see that
Brendon graduating Colin will be going
to location and our whole lives are
really kind of going into adulthood and
yet we want to be together so you've
given us a great developed mature space
so thank you for all your hard work
what do you hope for 20 to 30 years from
now but I hope for for Colin in his
future is the same that I hope for for
my neurotypical son I want him to feel
confident in seeking out his own path no
one has a perfect life but that's
something that's very meaningful to me
yeah is that he gets to choose the same
way we all get to choose I just want to
keep equipping him in that way
I think we all put in a lot of sweat and
energy and muscle honestly just seeing
Colin excited and jumping on his rug
really made it all worth it the family
seems so excited feeling renewed and
that's always the goal at home you're
trying to recharge can't wait to see how
they experience it throughout the week
and months and years really have
impacted our life here until next time
rest well you deserve it
[Music]